بعد الفوز المقنع في مستهل المشوار
بثلاثيه في شباك تنزانيا سيكون اسود
الاطلس امام فرصه لضمان بطاقه التاهل
للدور المقبل من كاس امم افريقيا من بوابه
منتخب جمهوريه الكونجو الديمقراطيه الذي
اكتفى بنقطه التعادل في ظهوره الاول وتبدو
الطريق معبده امام رفاق حكيم زياش لتحقيق
الفوز الثاني تواليا في دوري المجموعات
خصوصا بعد الاداء المميز ضد تنزانيا والذي
ح باشاده كبيره من الجماهير المغربيه
وذكرت بعض التقارير الصحفيه ان المدرب
وليد الرجراجي قد يجري تغييرين على تشكيله
المنتخب المغربي ويتعلق الامر بكل من امين
عدلي الذي قد يبدا المباراه اساسيا على
حساب عبد الصمد الزلزولي اضافه الى سفيان
بوفال والذي تبدو فرصته كبيره ايضا في
المشاركه اساسيا بعد اكتمال جاهزيته
الصحيه
والبدنيه الله